you know we're we're good but it's not
the it's the same I think I think just
life isn't the same yeah I think I'm in
a different place
Kourtney Kardashian gets real about
where she stands with her sisters Chloe
and Kim we're just you know living our
best lives and
yeah the push Founders candid confession
happens on the not skinny but not fat
podcast where she agrees with host
Amanda Hirsch that her relationship with
Coco isn't what it used to be I feel
like I've noticed but also the fans have
really noticed is Courtney and Chloe
used to be Courtney and Chloe yep like
the dragging you on the floor waxing
each other's vaginas wash your legs
you guys have that special special
relationship and it was it was like Kim
was kind of like the outsider for years
yeah and I feel like she could handle
that because she's like
could handle that like being on our own
Vibe but like
how does it feel now where it does kind
of seem like it's more Kim and Chloe the
reason because the two were having
babies at the same time I think that
when
Chloe was pregnant but with true
and then I think
was Kim pregnant did they have kids oh
they had kids at the same time she had a
surrogate at that time right maybe yeah
so I just felt like they really bonded
Bond like they were going through the
same things I mean just I think after
having kids it just is such a life
changer on top of that Courtney also put
some blame on her feelings about their
reality show I'm just
decided to
spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there I mean we
definitely love Courtney and we will
miss Courtney and whatever she decides
to do but people come people go all the
time this family we feel like it's a
revolving door Courtney says it felt
like her sisters turned on her
do it already
immediately stop okay stop then I felt
like
that's when I was unhappy with the show
partially because of them too kind of
ganging up I felt like it was
almost everything that Chloe and I had
done to Kim and then they were like kind
of flipping it on me it was like
everything and then I mean to be like
pushed to the point of like not not that
anyone pushed me but it was like the
daily stuff to where I like had the rage
inside to like scratch my sister but
court says despite being at different
stages in their life she still has
nothing but love for them both I feel
like Chloe and I are good I spoke to her
like the whole time she was in Milan we
were you know FaceTiming you know we're
we're good but it's not the it's the
same I think I think just life isn't the
same yeah I think I'm in a different
place I think some of us more than
others like feel the need to distance
sometimes or just do our own thing have
our own thing it can be like also
interconnected right
foreign